ce matin les nouveaux dirigeants l'yonne
il y ait ce coup le numéro un est aussi
le nouveau premier ministre herman tous
deux se sont expliqués en exclusivité à
nos envoyés spéciaux sur les objectifs
mais aussi sur cette exécution rapide de
l'ancien dictateur et de sa femme
interview exclusive est ce que vous me
croyez pas qu'en supprimant les
dictateurs suprêmement monsieur curtis
coup vous priver de là près du principal
témoin du principal responsable de tout
ce qui vous est arrivé de tout ce qui
vous a apprécié plus 25 ans et que j'ai
mais vous ne pourrez établir les réelles
responsabilités aujourd'hui c'est pas
aussi nous sommes des personnes qui
sentait le processus très spontané qui
nous précèdent eux seuls ces processus
bien sûr la pression de groupes
terroristes qui voudraient les libérer
nous avons su mais notre responsabilité
commune du conseil mais nous avons
utilisé avec tous les détails la
légalité existantes frugalité de gestion
c'est à dire nous avons instruit un
processus dans lequel oui mais bon il
devait se soumettre parce que c'était un
tribunal militaire organisée d'après
certains présument donc certaines normes
qui ont été respectées il inclut des
assesseurs populaire du temps du fait du
régime de monsieur touché ce cours d'eau
qu'est ce que c'est le dernier acte
la dictature est ce que c'est la
première faute de la démocratie c'est
pas une faute de la démocratie ou peut
être si c'est peut-être c'est une
chouette mais on ne pouvait pas venir
mais non je répète nous étions dans des
circonstances qui nous permettait nous
le pensons nous pensons aujourd'hui
encore plus qu'hier qui nous permettait
de nous attendre en comme une situation
d'instabilité
il y avait un ami
vous pouvez préciser c'est même plus que
ça il y avait des pressions nous avons
besoin d'informations concernant
d'éventuelles attaques sur les lieux
oui c'est trouver